every vote counts here for the largest
party in morocco's parliament but the
conservative justice and development
party has to reckon with a new and
unusual system of allocating votes that
the party's leaders say is specifically
designed to reduce their influence
seats in local and national assemblies
will be divided by the number of
registered voters regardless of whether
or not they cast ballots
unfortunately the aim of this law which
was passed by opposition parties and
those in coalition with us is to
minimise the justice and development
party that's why we rejected it from the
outset it's a strange a very strange law
its aim is to limit the pjd's chance of
winning
the biggest challenge for all the
political parties is persuading people
to vote one major survey suggests 64
percent of moroccans won't bother and
the real power still lies in the hands
of king mohammed vi
he takes all the major strategic
economic decisions
the king allowed constitutional reform
after the arab spring 10 years ago
political parties were given a greater
role in policy but mohammed vi appoints
the government and hires or fires
cabinet ministers
the new way of calculating houses are
allocated will stop one party dominating
which is what happened in the two
previous elections when the pjd achieved
important results
now the day will be opened for smaller
parties the constitutional court has
also ruled that this new law doesn't go
against the constitution
the second largest party in parliament
is the authenticity and modernity party
founded by a former adviser to the king
it's viewed by diplomats and the local
press as being close to the palace its
candidate for mayor and marrakech
rejects suggestions that the new law is
unfair
you can't stop morocco from trying its
own experiment
don't we have the right to do our own
experiment or do we have to always worry
about what the europeans will say
every time we're taking a step forward
in democracy with our own tools
the new system is expected to result in
coalitions made up of many parties that
could make governments weaker and it's
being brought in during the pandemic
when the king is consolidating his power
by taking all major decisions from
buying vaccines to economic support
packages
bernard smith al-jazeera marrakech